nice i was sucking from oxfam again over
those who might see me before and i'm
just going to talk about what I think
that's going on here in terms of growth
in the economy it's really why that was
painless not to know about what's very
interesting consciously and yet they're
going to be the ones i can be hit with
so often slightly later in the hole as
the whole economy changes obviously very
differently depending on the different
countries with no immersion economist
swimming at consumed on the town or
people are losing on the commodity
prices so i think i have a long way to
go with other people and i wish it would
pop up on each other do the other liquid
I'm concerned about is the it's not
change in the way actually activates
it's not found to be economy and yet
this is such an absolutely equity air
but I've also where because i've been in
some sessions and on climate change
where people here just don't you to get
more people in the South field of
analyst and there is an almost anger not
much very few people which they probably
don't know but amongst the elites in the
ministry what is being done for
evolution we just realized countries
really need you for money in through the
deal with four countries to adapt and I
Duke Leto some people here get than that
part of the deal and that most people in
the town that I mean they're talking
about these shows an issue at justice
and so I think it's a long way to go and
obviously I'm spending my time going
those meetings try to make sure that
those people want to get put in